we're standing outside of Lakewood
Church and you see all the folks lined
up to get aid right now this is also the
home for pastor Joel Osteen and we are
the only show that was invited inside
the doors and we had to ask him
point-blank did he wait too long to
start delivering aid now there was a
gentleman who posted a video put his
camera up to the window saying that
there's no water in here why aren't the
doors open I can't get in you know it
depends on what day that is that Street
could flood and in 14 hours that can be
down
where was the flooding inside was one
foot from coming over this flood wall we
tore Joel's megachurch which started
accepting evacuees on Tuesday they've
taken in about 400 people and Counting
but that hasn't stopped the online
shaming people out there gonna say well
he changed his mind because critics
forced him to do what do you say to that
you know again Kevin I don't really
think about it I can be at peace because
I know we did the right thing this seats
what 16,000 people so why wouldn't you
bring people in here why wouldn't you
open this up right now we'll take as
many as we can and we're happy to do it
if we need to do it now across from the
church this hotel housed evacuees from
day one but a nearby Starbucks was
closed due to water damage Joel says the
city never asked Lakewood to be a
shelter should you have prepared for
this situation had we had known it was
going to be this huge of a flood we
would have prepared sooner but you know
even our volunteers and our staff
couldn't get to the building last night
Lakewood held its first service since
the storm Joe became emotional as they
paid tribute to the victims this morning
people on foot and in cars lined up to
get essentials they especially need baby
products in hindsight would you have
opened this place up and put 500 beds in
here I think in hindsight if we knew
this storm was going to hit befool
knowing what you know now no one would I
know now I would have put staff in here
before the storm hit put beds do
everything we could to be prepared now
pastor Osteen really tried to focus on
the future he is gonna dedicate 12
members of his staff to focusing just on
the victim from Harvey not only helping
them get the essentials they need
so helping them financially